it's been a crazy year for insane
processor progression at the house of
cook as Apple has served up its latest
and most powerful M3 chip in three
flavors there's the M3 M3 Pro and M3 Max
all delivered in their newest lineup of
Apple devices and we have the family of
machines right here with us the iMac
MacBook Pro 14 and MacBook Pro 16 Apple
am chips are a family of system on chip
processors used in Mac computers and the
first M1 was released back in November
2020 3 years later the M3 family has
been released for Mac desktops and
notebooks and what's even more
surprising is that while the M2 was
announced in June 2022 the M2 Pro and M2
Max chips were launched in January 2023
this year just 10 months ago and already
we have the M3 Pro and M3 Max upgrades
in record time Apple chill out faster
and better that's what the latest chips
are but what's new is that apple is
using a new 3 nanom production process
for the M3 which is the same use for the
a77 pro chips for the iPhone 15 Pro
Models this new architecture not only
provides faster performance than
previous models it also makes the M3
line of laptops more power efficient and
apple says these laptops can last up to
22 hours and if you've ever used a
laptop until the battery ran out of
juice you know that anything more than
10 hours is amazing on top of this the
M3 chips also has some powerful features
like Dynamic caching Hardware
accelerated mes shading and Ray tracing
but the first thing you'll notice is not
the chip but the new space black color
and we know black is the absence of
light and therefore not really a color
right but take a look at these lovely
space gray and space black MacBook Pro
14 and 16 machines just look at the
Sheen and the texture and the way light
barely bounces off it black laptops are
nothing new to look at right but with
just a simple Flex Apple has again
turned something mundane into something
extremely beautiful meanwhile the new
iMac that we have on hand is a pretty
shade of blue at full 24 in of Glory
making this the second iMac on the mchip
as there was never an M2 iMac here we
have the iMac and MacBook Pro 14 powered
by the base M3 chip and the MacBook Pro
16 with the top of the line M3 Max under
the hood so how do they perform well we
have some 4K footage to try them out
with so we do have a Macbook air15 on
hand with an M2 Chip so it's going to be
a little challenge between this and the
MacBook Pro 14 since it runs the base M3
chip so this would be a nice little hit
to hit between the M2 and M3
performance- wise the M3 offers a core
CPU 10 core GPU and up to 24 gigs of
unified memory while the M3 Pro gets up
to 12 core CPU up to 18 core GPU and up
to 36 gigs unified memory the M3 Max is
only for this MacBook Pro 16 and has up
to 16 core CPU up to 40 core GPU and up
to 128 gigs unified memory the M3 can be
found on the new iMac and MacBook Pro 14
while the M3 Pro can be found on the
MacBook Pro 14 and 16 so before we get
into the test here's a message my
friends at secret lab here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but secret lab gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of Forman
function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co all right so we the 15 over
here with the M2 Chip and with the 14
with the M3 and we're going to be
running through scrubbing and also
seeing how fast each MacBook exports
with their respective chips so let's
just do that real quick we are starting
with the 15 that is the M2 Chip and it's
not plugged in so everything's going on
battery and let's see how well this
thing scrubs and as you can see it's
pretty smooth but of course the main
question is how long it will take for it
to export the entire video and it's
about it's about 5 minutes now 5 minutes
and 30 seconds long so we'll have to
check that out let's see how fast this
15 takes to export with the M2 Chip we
are at render and maximum depth maximum
render quality is ticked off as well
cbr2 so let's hit the X and hit that
together at the same time yeah let's go
one two
3 okay so we're coming into the final
10% of the export and we're running
about 6 minutes and 27 seconds for about
5 minutes and 30 seconds of 4K footage
with Boll with some Boll and supers and
graphics and everything so it's running
as expected I've been working with the
15 C it's launch and here wait up hold
on all right and here we
we we go okay so the xot takes about 7
minutes for about 5 minutes and 30
seconds of 4K footage with some Boll
inlaid and supers and graphics and
whatever I've been working with this
since it's launch and honestly it has
been amazing so far with that M3 chip
even at that point of time anything with
an M1 was great already and the M2 just
pushed that even further and now let's
see how the M3 works out so same deal
with the MacBook Pro 14 we're not
plugged in we're running solely on
battery it the full over here and let's
see how scrubbing is like it's the same
project as the one on D15 and as you can
see it's buty smooth as well just look
at
that render maximum depth maximum render
quality cbr2 all right so let's hit the
export button and let's see how long
this
takes all right lost 10% of the export
and yeah this thing is lightning fast
look at that PR not even near 7 minutes
right now and we 92% in the last 22 is
seconds of the export according to
premere Pro and let's get ready to stop
this 15 more
seconds man okay that is fast yeah let's
go 5 4 3 2 one
and yep oh okay but that's the final
time for this whole export so this
basically backs up Apple's caim okay so
for funsies we're going to be running
the same export on my PC over here here
we are running a 12 gen i7 we also have
32 gigs of RAM and for the GPU we are
running a Nvidia gForce 380 so let's see
how that FS with premium Pro let me just
get the project file up real quick so as
you can see the scrubbing is relatively
smooth but obviously not as smooth as
the M2 or the M3 chips right now so
let's see how long my PC takes to export
this project have everything on render
maximum depth using maximum render
quality and of course cbr2 the same as
the other the same as the Mac the same
as the Mac so let's just export this
real quick let us start our export right
now again this is a gaming PC and also
it's plugged in so so it's not exactly a
fair comparison to the MacBook Pro 14 we
have at the back and so okay so it's
about a minute and 47 seconds 77.5
seconds you know the the PC is plugged
in man come on the PC is plugged in and
we running quite a bit of spec so it's
not exactly the fairest comparison but
it's just for fun obviously the Mac
Studio with an M2 Ultra or an M3 would
beat out the PC like flat out so this
just for fun all right but still like
got damn so performance- wise this is
what you're in for when it comes to
these MacBook Pros when equipped with
the M3 but can they run crisis I'm
joking but for real let's try out
Resident Evil Village on the6 and see if
native AAA gaming truly has a place in
the realm of
Macos all right let's check settings
real quick
display HD R mode okay full
screen thing Graphics memor frame rate
variable let's put down
120 screen vertical synchronization
metal effects
upscaling all right oh
high what's the highest I can go high
[Music]
eight let's go high as well
for M qualities High Max let's go let's
wack
everything y w
that
on high H quality as well contrast
everything is stand on death the
field yeah I know we don't need film
Noise Okay
sick okay so I think we're set for a
game let's go back
and just increase brightness a little
bit more I mean really when it comes to
playing these games like this and
testing them out like you really need to
sit down and play for yourselves to
understand how it's like I mean
obviously but so far like I am enjoying
myself I just want to see how the game
fast like when it comes to combat so if
you didn't already know Resident Evil
Village is a very dark
game in both senses so the M3 Max is
really doing the work right now let's
look at this photo frame really good
especially with how the light hits off
the fourth door and the frame
individually you even see the Green in
the fourth door so that's
nice no no friendly
friendly who are you who sent you nobody
there was an accident down the
road what's going
on oh he looks really good though hey
are you listen
hey
nice what
the
so we kind of made it this FY I
think the camera kind of stopped because
of the
uh because the camera is overheated
but wow this looks really good right off
the bat and you guys just need to try
this out for yourself I mean I play
Village on the iPhone already you can
check the video if you want but on the M
ult TR and playing on the macro Pro 6
this thing has been quite the experience
the speakers are amazing the graphics
look really good just look at his hair
and everything that's going on here the
combat is Resident Evil right but who
would have
thought tripa gaming does have a space
in the ma as well let's continue yes
here's the meden crest that's for the
depression
in yes Save let's just get out of these
fuels
first oh there he is oh my God okay here
we
go I missed one shot already so that's
not that's not
good okay so that's two down and I am
out of ammo so that's
cool there we
go okay okay cool all right all right
okay
[Music]
nice okay let's get
back damn the fire's moving
fast what are you thinking step back we
can bust out with
this
here we
go why the is this happening
again
oh transitions between doing cut
scenes all really
good you're you're not
local even
better mother Miranda is going to love
you all right sick I think we have
enough as you can see the MacBook Pro 16
with the M3 mags is the most powerful
but how powerful well we ran geek bench
6 a benchmark has to measure performance
and this laptop the latest that Apple
has is on par with this supop Mac Studio
that we have that is running M2 Ultra
and the Mac Studio was released less
than 5 months ago which means that in
just 5 months Apple has launched a
laptop that performs as well as its high
performing desktop that's insane let's
so just let that sink in so there we
have it Apple has been putting out M
series chips for their machines and
tablets and they AR planning on stock
shopping it's really just another day in
the office for them with classic apple
designs and their drive to create faster
and more powerful Tech to keep them at
the top of their game if you've got any
questions about these devices let me
know in the comments below and I'll do
my best to get to them if you like what
you're watching keep up with us on all
our socials right here because we post
stuff every day and maybe hit the like
And subscribe buttons it'll help us out
a lot have a great weekend if you want
to see more stuff check this
out
[Music]
a